sí
guau qué bien se es de acá
ahora que preguntaban si alguien se
enamorado alguien está enamorado yo viví
en poquitas manos nadie se ha enamorado
bueno quienes se han enamorado alguna
vez de la vida
allá hay allá va va mejorando mejorando
la la perspectiva de la esperanza pero
pero de ese amor que uno dice es el amor
de mi vida es con este si para siempre
bueno lo que dure el para siempre este y
que de pronto pensamos y empezamos a
crear planes y cómo formalizar y bueno
pues eventualmente cuando empieza esta
cosquillita del amor pues dicen por ahí
que el dinero y el amor no se pueden
ocultar los vamos a demostrar el amor y
lo queremos enseñar y lo queremos
compartir con todas y todos en la casa
en la familia en el trabajo todos lados
porque estamos felizmente enamorados y
bueno pues entonces ese ese es el amor
qué hace qué hace una defensora de
derechos humanos hablando de amor pero
bueno pues está interesante pero a ver
de todas estas manos animosa es que
dijeron que se habían enamorado alguna
vez dígame quién se ha enamorado alguna
vez de una persona de su mismo sexo
solamente vio tres manos cuatro manos
están muy bien miren no se preocupen
ustedes son muy jóvenes yo a su edad
tampoco creo que me había enamorado y
menos de alguien de mi mismo sexo
todavía hay tiempo todavía tenemos
tiempo y es que esto de hablar del amor
entre dos personas del mismo sexo
resultado pues a veces complejo a veces
así como que estamos en las siguientes
acomodamos y no no no no acaba de
acomodar y porque miren datos de la
encuesta nacional sobre discriminación
dicen que 4 de cada 10 personas señalan
que la preferencia sexual es una de las
cosas que mayormente divide a la
sociedad en el mismo sentido una
proporción similar también señala que 4
de cada 10 personas dicen que no
estarían dispuestos o dispuestas a
compartir su casa con una persona que
tiene una orientación distinta al
heterosexual
entonces estas estas cifras si nos hacen
de pronto pensar que la condición de
amar que la condición de amar y que
tendría que ser algo maravilloso para
algunas de nosotras nosotros se vuelve
complicado porque entonces tenemos que
pasar bajo unos estándares distintos
para mostrar el amor de manera abierta
estándares distintos para mostrar
también el amor en nuestros espacios
públicos para que nuestras parejas
puedan tener acceso a todos los derechos
como si los tuviera una pareja
heterosexual a la seguridad social a la
vivienda a las prestaciones sociales al
derecho a heredar entonces es es muy
complicado
se empiezan a construir estas ideas de
cierto rechazo y de cierta incomodidad
yo les quiero pedir un gran favor en
este momento para que me ayuden a hacer
el siguiente ejercicio si podemos cerrar
por un momentito los ojos y pensar
que estamos enamoradas o enamorados de
alguien de nuestro mismo sexo
y en el mismo espacio en el que están
depronto visualizar
como diríamos esta noche a una escena
que hay en nuestra casa
como llegamos con esa persona que amamos
y que quizá es la primera vez que la
vamos a llevar a nuestra casa
cuál va a ser la primera reacción al
abrir la puerta y encontrar a la familia
la mamá
como lo viviríamos cada una y uno de
ustedes
consideran que habría una situación de
rechazo
de aceptación
de enojo
implicaría que quizás nos correrán del
domicilio por eso por habernos atrevido
a llegar con una persona de nuestro
mismo sexo
complicado
ahora pensemos en esa misma imagen pero
nuestro empleo
hay una fiesta anual nos invitan e
incluso quizás vayamos a recibir un
reconocimiento por nuestro desempeño
laboral
y de pronto dicen es el momento de
llegar acompañado o acampar
de la persona que amo
y llegan con una persona de su mismo
sexo que es el amor de su vida
o que es en ese momento la persona que
sienten que es el amor de su vida
qué pasaría con sus compañeras y
compañeros de trabajo
les aceptarían
les daría gusto
veía rarito
qué pasaría
tendríamos miedo de llegar al día
siguiente a nuestro empleo
y saber que seguramente nos dirían
híjole
habrá un recorte laboral y pues
reconocemos tu destacada trayectoria
pero pues eres una de las personas que
se tendrán que ir de la empresa
último ejemplo pensemos en nuestra
escuela
hay una fiesta anual que nos vamos a
reencontrar con los amigos de la
generación a los que no habíamos visto
por un buen rato
y de pronto pues no sabemos un poco qué
ha pasado con las historias quién se fue
de viaje quien regresó quién estudió una
materia en el extranjero quién sabe pero
llegamos con una persona de nuestro
mismo sexo tomada de la mano
cuál sería la sensación
de llegar en ese espacio con nuestras
personas que habíamos compartido algún
espacio escolar
sería de aceptación sería de emoción
sería de sorpresa sería como o sea como
cuando pasó y con pasos con razón o ve
no vendría las bromas apps con razón
desde la escuela tú te veías que eras
rarito o la otra pasaría
como me pasó a mí
de pronto los amigos dejaron de hablar
alguno
entonces
pensar en estos ejemplos y les agradezco
al momento de acompañarme a hacer este
ejercicio pensar en estos en estos
espacios si nos permite colocarnos en
una situación de empatía con una persona
que tiene una inclinación erótico
afectiva con alguien de su mismo sexo y
que eso es pensar en algo tan sencillo
como es el amor y que justo por
enamorarse de una persona
un mismo sexo puede estar viviendo
obstáculos en su vida puede estar
viviendo discriminación puede estar
viviendo violencia laboral puede estar
viviendo acoso o las bromas simbólicas
que de pronto escuchamos en muchos
espacios para segregar o disminuir de
pronto los derechos de las personas
dentro del trabajo que he realizado de
hace un tiempo estaba en el consejo
nacional para prevenir la discriminación
tuve la oportunidad de poder conocer
muchísimos casos y donde descubrir que
la discriminación por preferencia u
orientación sexual
lástima la parte más profunda de una
persona y lástima la parte más profunda
de una persona en su dignidad pero
también esto ocurre en los espacios más
cercanos porque a diferencia de otros
tipos de discriminación estas
circunstancias se llegan a dar
principalmente en el hogar
el nivel de pronto de rechazo que viven
las personas que tienen una preferencia
sexual distinta a la heterosexual es
mayúsculo dentro del primer espacio en
la familia y entonces esto es un poco
analizar cómo se va construyendo cómo se
van construyendo estos prejuicios o
estos estereotipos las familias de
pronto piensan que hice mal en que me
equivoqué algo hice mal yo no eduqué a
mi hijo para ser homosexual yo no eduqué
a mi hija para ser lesbiana y es que es
claro eso no se aprende no es una
situación de educación es una situación
que cada persona tiene de manera
individual y que cada persona lo puede
asumir o entender en los diferentes
espacios y en los diferentes momentos
hay un gran compromiso de las
instituciones educativas para hablar de
estos espacios para hablar de estos
temas en el ámbito educativo es uno
donde mayormente también se vive
discriminación tuve la fortuna de tener
un caso justo de la escuela donde se es
yo estudiaba la secundaria una joven que
tenía claramente identificada su
orientación sexual como como como
adolescente lesbiana de pronto empezó a
vivir una situación de acoso terrible en
la escuela no la dejaban ir al baño sola
no la dejaban ir al baño acompañada
tenía que ir con algunas de las
perfectas las seguían no le permitían de
pronto salir del salón a menos que
estuviera vigilada y una situación de
acoso que la llevó a vivir una crisis y
un proceso de depresión muy complicado
hacer una intervención en los espacios
educativos como este fue fundamental
para poder llegar a cambiar todo lo que
se pensaba de esta joven al interior de
la escuela y al momento por ejemplo de
haber resuelto ese caso
es un evento de disculpa pública y en el
evento de disculpa pública cuando el
director de la escuela estaba señalando
que desde la institución se había
cometido un acto de discriminación
un grupo importante de alumnas
aproximadamente 50 dieron la espalda
s darle espaldera mostrar el rechazo
hacia lo que en ese momento se estaba
realizando
yo me puse a pensar en ese momento
hoy está pasando esta situación con esta
joven y esas compañeras casi 50 le
dieron la espalda que va a pasar el día
que alguna de ellas sufra alguna
circunstancia también de discriminación
y alguien le dé la espalda
tenemos que buscar espacios mucho más
empáticos mucho más incluyentes mucho
más amorosos una de las grandes
preocupaciones y con esto quiero cerrar
es decir cómo hacemos para explicar la
diversidad sexual a los niños porque esa
es la gran preocupación y yo me pregunto
si vamos por la calle caminando y de
pronto encontramos un puesto de
periódico y con escenas muy claras sobre
violencia explícita muy explícita pues
parece que es muy sencillo explicar que
lo que ahí vemos es el reflejo de la
violencia y que la violencia se ha
vuelto un parte cotidiano de eso bueno
pues la misma explicación le podemos dar
a un niño oa una niña cuando en la calle
van dos personas del mismo sexo tomadas
de la mano lo que están viendo
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]